this week we've got insta bug eat slop
and tire bed I think I know what
insta-buck is what since the bug we
looking forward so weird I gained a
million
that's so weird I hate I was like my
three followers I last like 15,000 broad
because that means you're not allowed no
way I got a check with not it went back
and went back no everyone agrees that
the first story it is okay let's listen
alright so yeah there was this um bug
that would just wiped out a lot of
followers I came back I came back yeah
but now it's back they fixed it but
initially cuz I hit up on a girl chat
and I'll just like guys I think they did
another purge like a lot of us y'all the
bots
I don't mind purchase I thought it was
good too I agree I agree cuz then I just
want the ones I paid for I haven't
really posted much on Instagram in the
last two years but I'm starting again
trying to be better that's good so she
had a laundry 245 million and then three
million Ariana Grande what's she do
singer she lost three million for thank
you
thanks I don't roll that some swag she's
married his mom to well we know that
your taste is a little wonky with that
for like the eighties your second the
eighty
I don't like eighties music her dog look
nice you said John Denver who the [ __ ]
we talked about oh my god everyone's
gonna know John Denver and you are all
gonna look down John Denver's like the
best folk singer all-time thumbs up if
you know you changed it to count you
change it from country to so it is
country if you think our fan base is
gonna have your back over ours not not
back but they'll know who John Denver
everyone's gonna know doctor but who the
[ __ ] is John Denver's a license I'm with
stupid Johnny Cash okay you try no
Johnny Cash your same thing
all right okay here let me let me lift
up the curtain so that you can see what
the [ __ ] magic trick is yeah we don't
give a [ __ ] we're just pull it [ __ ]
busting your balls all right get it get
over let me up pull that curtain back
down so I don't have to look at Geo the
rest of the day continue with the story
did you live near Folsom I'm right next
to focus you like Folsom City yeah okay
we have a whole trail for Johnny give
him a [ __ ] tissue
did you watch this Folsom Prison
performance no I think I was a little
did you watch the Johnny Cash biopic
yeah I did yeah from the other look so
pretty when you close your mouth don't
open your mouth all right let's do it
everybody freaked out James Charlesworth
oh yeah he did it Jake Charles I'm a
girl
James trouser here watches him yet oh I
want to damn if you watch this can you
be on the show yeah to be on it when
he's here I don't show me the gay guy
with the rosy cheek he was the first
covergirl he was the first cover and the
first covergirl guy on YouTube so he's
hot man yeah he's making much money
money he got rosy cheeks all the time
it's rosie
excuse me everything yes hi sisters
welcome back to my channel I watch him
all right
so why'd he freak out just cuz people
last fall no he lost familiars though
have fun but if they're BOTS
I like I just assume they're bottles all
right yeah but then when you're off when
you're working with brands right they're
looking at
they don't care how many pots up they
just see numbers like ooh let me cash in
on those numbers but if you're that
person then you just buy bubs
no but if that's your mindset you can
but you you would like to assume that
you don't have that many pots well now
there's websites where companies can
check your stats and they can see if
your phone a lot of companies ask you to
send a in site you can also alter all
that [ __ ] I just think sometimes people
see the big numbers and they don't even
look at the likes and they're just like
big number let's get them you know smart
companies do they look at interaction
comments all that well I even think even
like doing collabs sometimes like this
sounds weird but I always look at the
numbers if it's special it's business
only like I want to know that your
followers listen to you and then you
have a relationship with them more than
just like oh I'm just gonna throw like
whatever at you yeah but likes are one
thing too if you're talking business and
dollars or another thing right but we're
assuming that if you're followers like
you they're gonna buy whatever you tell
them a DoubleTap is a much easier
transact comments never oh yeah better
but still a credit cards talk credit
card stuff that's true no I'm just
saying that someone can I've known
people with millions of followers
I've known more than that no pool and
they get 200,000 likes yeah and they
have no money like even our boom-boom on
blasts all your pool what oh we've been
told by companies that like they've
worked with people with bigger numbers
and are like are what's that were called
engage minutes our engagement is way
higher bass rock you create a
relationship with your followers like
they know a lot about you [ __ ] crazy
Titus and he's not even engaging with
them get so many fan pages Oh gets more
life than I do you share baby oh it's so
easy it's so easy no I believe me I'm
not I'm scared Tom's gonna have the
first one or make it on this pretty easy
so a is your I didn't do any of this
somebody else did this Russia or
something they just said it was a bug
but you know it's funny
happened right after the new update the
iOS update oh there was a bug in there
update because I have a droid I don't
know any business my own my own
assumption because I've noticed that
after I updated my I didn't do it that's
why it didn't happen to me Casey didn't
update his phone and didn't happen to
him either but then when he saw my page
through his phone it was still the old
number what a trip that is kind of true
but it's fixed that's when you should
have a third phone so you could pull up
your Instagram account and then take a
picture the third phone at different
numbers of the same account and then a
GoPro on your head and then a GoPro on
your head you have an iPad yeah do that
there's a lot of cameras everywhere all
over true should it all those all right
move on to the next story this is the
short one what it was kind of funny so
this woman named Jennifer is 48 years
old yeah Jennifer yeah in Florida you
know I heard about that Florida can I
put it out there yes so Florida
everyone's leaving kind of tie that have
I got a bad back so bad things don't
happen of thought is no crazier than
other states Florida has a policy with
their police and news that they can get
stories immediately and it's all public
record other states don't so are other
states are just [ __ ] is crazy but
it's harder for websites to get you know
whatever to get the story from
California I think la would be [ __ ]
cool ya know and I think there is some
crazy in Florida for sure because
there's money in drugs and a lot of
stuff going on and some of their laws
are a little bit more free than other
states but generally speaking I heard
and you can fact check me out [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] but I heard that that's why all
weird things always happen in Florida
that'd be dope if they did it for all
the states so then we would have way
more stories to talk about I'm Jamie
that's true
I need no work that's true cuz when you
look at it like the top ten most like
city with the highest crime or the worst
CD or the most poverty or whatever
Florida's not in there now it's always
like Detroit or like something you know
if stories were out everywhere we know a
lot more about what's the hell's going
out of Chicago
yeah like if we don't know [ __ ] you just
clear
murder like every week or some [ __ ] like
it's pretty crazy yeah but this one
Jennifer here Jennifer
she wasn't arrested on battery charges
after she beat her boyfriend with a
frozen pork chops oh [ __ ] it's a big
pork chop on it dude that could be an
oxide you're fighting my book she beat
up with a pork chop what do you do
though any why don't you grab a skillet
you did something they always do it
you're just people first got the pork
chop book of a question I'm Alison so I
have this friend and he's wondering if
asking for friend if it's okay if it's
if it's okay for him to think it's funny
I have boys get their asses beat by that
girlfriend that's not funny my friends
asking this question I say your friend
should be confident in giggles not funny
I think it's the same thing it goes both
ways but when you're getting beat up
with a pork chop I think we can all
laugh a little bit I think it's [ __ ]
hilarious
God so thanks for asking for me I
answered your question in the beginning
of this when I said this was pretty
funny
yeah this is funny I think Mark Chapman
cuz some dudes get really sensitive
right like they're like well you need a
girl beat up the guy's not funny
well let's not let them but that's
pretty hard ruin our laughter I mean my
friends think it's funny cuz that [ __ ]
is [ __ ] funny you know but - it's
dangerous - cuz have you ever had it's a
rock dude oh yeah frozen me yeah that
[ __ ] comes out like a [ __ ] break dude
where do you grab it - like pork chops
like that yeah like maybe 10 ounces
that's just a ninja unless it's bone in
the rack of lamb is it bone in a rack of
lamb or a ribs or something now you're
talking about it I feel like just one
pork chop really isn't all that the man
suffered a half inch cut I don't know
where [ __ ] cut up beat anybody
perfect yeah she must be a shot putter
or something oh
she hasn't slept in days he deserved I
he deserve money on drugs
no it looks like she got beat up by both
ways for sure yeah they're reporting
that there was a verbal argument and
then that doesn't look verbal my eyes
don't turn purple after verbal abuse
this is not the first time they probably
had something like this for her to grab
a [ __ ] pork chop and be like you know
what [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] just been saving
that pork chop yeah probably
she went she put water in the back that
she's freaking yeah well they're saying
that there's a knife wrapped on it the
boyfriend fled the house after she threw
the police determined that she was the
primary aggressor
so that's why she was the one that was
arrested a man charges she she probably
got beat the [ __ ] up put the WOM pork
chop and then that was that she got
accused for it I love that in your book
she's like the same not she's not she's
not but it happens often it happens
often we're like they're getting beat
the [ __ ] up and you swing once and then
let's say the person I hit second and
gets in trouble or something
Oh teachers always you see all that is
all that school rules yeah you know like
I'm [ __ ] with Joe and they joke
finally just sucks man he's the one
gonna principal what that's what I'm
sneaky with it I'm sneaky with them off
with it that's what always happened oh
yeah I'll be like he started it and
they're like doesn't matter who started
it yeah I saw you lost control you yeah
stupid ass rules
stupid ass principle yeah maybe they're
trying to do self control I know but I
never learned it I feel betrayed because
I'm like that's not fair I get both of
us in I wonder how they handle it now I
probably just cuz they switz with this
and they have like a blanket statement
where they're they're judging the kid
that's just like a small boiling like
you know what's that thing I used to do
like punch bug you see they're like a
low you don't right and they hit them
yeah this person hits back they're
judging that the same way as the kid
that's getting jumped by four people
really you know like if the kid jumps by
four is gene jump by four people and
like fights back they're still like well
you hit them back too so back to self
control when you're down there I know
right the [ __ ] there's like there's
every situations different you can't
judge them all curled up like a roly
poly truth is though I bet you I don't
want to play devil's advocate because
obviously I think everyone should get
trouble if you do [ __ ] up [ __ ] but I
don't
principals and teachers are like taught
how to handle that know we're tired of
that [ __ ] well they're just taught how
to teach English or they're talking how
to teach math they're not taught how to
like deal with gangs or a bully or no
one knows and who knows what that it's
right that's that supposed to be the
parents job if for sure - yeah shitty
ass parents school system I mean you got
to do that at a workplace to know for
sure but hopefully you're an adult
figure it out I'm sure they're just
tired of it and they're like hey at you
fine go yeah yeah yeah if it's not a big
deal you're both [ __ ] get it fine
okay you're in trouble go that's true
they're just annoyed I know I don't
think I could be a teacher no way I'll
let them fight all day yeah I'll be like
that's so cute yeah all right who's
who's got ten on the all the kids are
like holding up money like that
preschool if I got caught that they were
having the whole club the Hulk thing the
whole time the Hulk this one they were
like little preschool kids and then one
of them was crying we talked to Ron J
genious that's funny yeah then the mom
like students school and stuff like that
started recording it see that's where it
gets [ __ ] up is you can't record it
this stays here the kid was getting
[ __ ] up too bad - I'll pull them to
the side and I'll be like me and you
yeah meet me at 6:00 a.m. hands up hands
up yeah us it'll be there so for our
last story this Brazilian handyman is
turning tires into dogs pet beds dog and
cat that's why said pit oh he's like
shredding them up all that six oh that's
genius that's pretty cool yeah that's
genius
those are hella gay I'd sleep in that
yeah somebody's head that [ __ ] that's me
as a dog does he have any monster truck
be masa producing wants it with the Z
those look sick what's mimosa like a
mimosa Oh Paul fencing would that
sunbathe indeed Oh Ruth yeah you just
get a truck tire like your truck tires
come right come on that is so nice like
repurpose [ __ ] me too yeah like there's
just this littering problem of just old
tires all over
like no why don't they do what my and
what we probably that issue here to
about tire spotlight before we sell them
yeah but not if it's busted Oh like if
it's really really bad
oh yeah what do we do with that I think
they just go to a wasteland they just
lay there they don't just recycle the
plastic I miss our old uh marina I don't
think so the rubber don't some
children's playgrounds against the tires
some and I think Nike I think Nike even
made like a sneaker out of some I might
be wrong or shoot some shoe companies
but I think how many [ __ ] cars are
there in America there's a lot of tires
you go through a tire what every year or
two really if you got shitty EU roads I
don't know [ __ ] about where the tires go
trash is like it just calm it's done
have you been to like a junk yard junk
yard like a public junk yeah yeah yeah
whatever yeah cuz you could go and pick
a partner for your car those are all
well that's a pickup art play Oh like
I've been to those ones what's a public
junkyard well just like were you if we
just grabbed all this if you just sure
we have one no right off you ever do any
like a structure what's the recycling
center uh well it's similar one that's
not recycling plain where it looks like
mountains leg of truck trash and you can
see anything junkyard that's all right
yeah that's a landfill landfill that
though first that waste like a junkyard
wrong wrong terminology
yeah I live next to a landfill laughs
you did public there's no right on the
mountain there by Rose Hills I pictured
the landfill and then Joe raised up
property and this would get bigger with
time I think it's probably a bit use is
it public I bet you it's state or county
and they incinerate it right no I don't
know if they can no I think they just
yeah make it into a mountain
yeah they bury it dan you would be so
cool if we could just chuck our trash to
the Sun what I heard is they take all
the trailers send it to New Jersey all
of it imagine working there shot stone
sorry to Jersey I think you're lovely
Stacey they deliver it all then they
just [ __ ] drop it yeah like water or
a wildfire
yeah I just googled where does the trash
go or the trash is all the does it go
imagine all these years of trash and
trash and treasure - yeah like we were
trash man picks up your trash you gotta
go somewhere yes idly dang United States
is a top producer of municipal solid
waste [ __ ] yeah in the entire world
yeah about 251 million tons of trash
every year or does it go so it differs
between region states and even cities
some cities like San Francisco and
Seattle are able to recycle more ways
that's a lot of trash man body trash oh
there's more than 3,000 active landfills
scattered throughout the u.s. 3,000
that's not that many just over 52
percent of the country's garbage but
imagine wait what ends up in these 3,000
oh my pills imagine how big they are
3,000 well yeah they have to be huge for
200 was it 258 million tons oh my god
your eyes are gonna pop out the top what
the colonel is the Kurdish for the
curtain back oh cool ellee's the number
two city in the US that is recycling
recycles top cities let's don't you ask
first Francisco Los Angeles San Jose
Portland San Diego I mean it sounds like
it's dope I don't it all goes into it
but sounds like a selfie yes
the sad truth is it takes more energy to
recycle than to just throw it away so
like all the fossil fuels we burn and
everything yeah [ __ ] it up that's why
here - is it worse than throwing it away
and letting it sit there some processing
or landfill like what they do is they'll
go they'll take out all the recyclable
stuff anyway so it's like if you're
throwing away like they're still going
through just more work you know would be
bad yeah we made dog beds out of it all
aluminum can dog beds all of it dog
houses oh yeah a condom attic all of it
oh my god I always say those DIY things
like when you repurpose certain borrow a
tissue raft I never you know but I'm
like that is such a good idea
[Music]
[Music]